Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Es gibt neue Erkenntnisse zu Doping im Fußball. Die will ich einordnen mit Jonathan Sachse vom gemeinnützigen Recherchezentrum CORRECTIV. Jetzt im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 40. Jonathan, sei mir gegrüßt, schön, dass du dir mal wieder Zeit nimmst. So langsam kann man eine Chronologie des Fußballdopings allein anhand der von uns erstellten Rasenfunksendungen nacherzählen. Wir haben ein Tribüngespräch zu Doping im Fußball aufgenommen. Wir haben schon einen Kurzpass aufgenommen zu den Erkenntnissen rund um den VfB Stuttgart und den SC Freiburg in den 70ern und 80ern. Und jetzt gibt es wieder neue Informationen zu Doping im Fußball.
Genau, ja, sehr gutes Timing. Wir können uns jedes halbe Jahr spätestens treffen.
Ob das so gut ist, das müssen die Hörerinnen und Hörer beurteilen. Lasst uns gleich einen Blick auf die neuesten Erkenntnisse. Ein Leak durch Hacker erlaubt jetzt mal wieder einen Blick auf Doping im Fußball. Verschiedene Dokumente wurden mutmaßlich von der russischen Hackergruppe Fancy Bear an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht. Eines dieser Dokumente enthält eine Liste mit Namen von 25 Nationalspielern aus 13 Nationen, die bei der WM 2010 in Südafrika teilweise verbotene Substanzen für den eigenen Gebrauch ausgewiesen haben. Die SZ schreibt, unter den Spielern wären die Argentinier Diego Milito, Carlos Tevez, Juan Baron, Gabriel Heinze, Walter Samel und auch die Deutschen Mario Gómez, Dennis Aogo, Hans-Jörg Budt und Christian Dresch, der dann doch nicht mitgefahren ist, stehen auf dieser Liste. Erklär uns mal bitte kurz, was sagt denn diese Liste überhaupt aus?
Genau, es geht ja insgesamt um mehrere Dokumente, das vielleicht vorneweg, die in dem Leak enthalten sind, sogar noch mehr als wir bisher veröffentlicht haben. Da können wir vielleicht später noch drüber reden, kann ich noch was zu sagen. Und wenn wir jetzt über das erste Dokument sprechen, also eine Liste, wir sind 25 Nationalspieler von der WM 2010. Dort sind neben den Namen von Spielern sozusagen Substanzen aufgeschrieben, wofür sich die Spieler eine offizielle Genehmigung geholt haben, dass sie während des Turniers diese Medikamente nutzen dürfen. Und das sind hauptsächlich Substanzen, die auch Asthmatiker nehmen würden, wo man die Luftzufuhr, die Atmungsmöglichkeiten mit verbessern kann. Das sind keine großen schweren Dopingsubstanzen, aber Substanzen, wo man sich bei der Masse anschauen kann, wenn viele Spieler in einer Nationalmannschaft das nehmen, und sich die Frage stellen kann, sind das schwere Asthmatiker oder warum wollen die jetzt diese Medikamente nutzen?
Das ist die wichtige Einordnung. Es geht darum, dass sich die Spieler, die Ausnahmeregelungen, Genehmigungen haben, geben lassen, dass sie diese Mittel nehmen dürfen. Gleichzeitig kennen wir alle ja auch das Krankheitsbild von Asthma. Auf der anderen Seite ist die Quote von Asthmatikern im Spitzensport durchaus erstaunlich. Unter den Gesamtdeutschen sind es ungefähr 5 Prozent. Bei der Tour de France oder auch Olympischen Spielen sind es gerne mal ein Viertel bis die Hälfte aller Athleten, was Fragen aufwirft. Kannst du abschätzen, was ist der Vorteil, den man sich davon versprechen könnte?
Naja, wenn wir jetzt mal so hoch Leistungssportarten wie Radsport nehmen, wo es darum geht, konditionell ganz schön zu bolzen, also wo die Atmung eine wesentliche Rolle spielt, ist ja in jeder Sportart wichtig, aber ich meine zu Sportarten, wo es wirklich darum geht, den Berg hoch zu kloppen oder lange Strecken zu laufen, da ist es ja elementar, ob man da eine ziemlich reine Atmung hinbekommt und mit jedem Mal, wo man schwerer atmet, wird man auch gebremst bei der Strecke, die man bewältigen möchte. Da macht das glaube ich viel aus, ich bin ein wenig Zwiegespalten bei der Einordnung. Einerseits gibt es auch Studien, die ich auch für glaubwürdig halte, dass man tatsächlich auch zu einer Art Asmatiker werden kann in einer Sportart, in der man sozusagen so dauerhaft Höchstleistung bringen muss, auch im Training und so und dann irgendwann sich das Körperbild ein bisschen verändert. Das ist sozusagen die eine Seite, deswegen können wir auch nicht sagen, wie geht es wirklich jetzt diesen einzelnen Spielern, die das genommen haben, da haben sie wirklich auch ein Problem, dass sie da für diese Sondergenehmung brauchen, das finde ich, muss man immer so als aber dazu halten. Was ich aber trotzdem wichtig finde zu sagen, ist sozusagen, ob das, was beim Radsport zum Beispiel der Fall ist, einfach zu leicht so mitgegeben wird als okay, weil das geht ja immer wieder um die Frage, solche Sachen, wenn man sich jetzt dafür das Goholt für eine Substanz, dann ist vielleicht der Weg zu einer nächsten noch ein bisschen schwereren, noch mehr leistungssteigernden Substanz kleiner und dann irgendwann kommt man sehr schnell zum harten Doping und das finde ich ganz wichtig, da die Grenze genau zu ziehen. Lassen wir das erstmal bei dem einen Punkt zu deiner Frage, sonst komme ich gleich.
Wieder so ein Redefluss. Es ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert. Kann ich mir letztlich Asthma-Mittel dann so ein bisschen vorstellen, wie chemische Umsetzung eines Nasenpflasters, wie wir sie aus den 90ern kennen bei Bundesliga-Profis?
Ja, wo ja immer noch nicht klar ist, war das jetzt wirklich so ein positiver Effekt, oder hat Olaf Marschall das einfach nur so als Signature irgendwie gern mit sich rumgetragen? Das kann ich dir auch nach vorne sagen, aber das Prinzip soll ähnlich sein. Aber ich glaube schon, dass so ein Asthma-Spray eine eindeutige Wirkung hat, die ich mir bei diesem Pflaster immer noch nicht erklären kann. Ich habe es aber selbst nie ausprobiert.
Es war die Zeit der Pflaster, dann hatten es ja irgendwann die Hip-Hopper im Gesicht kleben und man wusste nicht mehr, was passiert hier eigentlich. Der DFB hat auf diese Veröffentlichung reagiert in einer Stellungnahme und weiß daraufhin, dass die medizinische Überprüfung von Asthma-Fällen ja erst zu dieser Ausnahmeregelung führt, die ja auch von der Antidopingagentur ausgestellt wird. Hast du denn Erkenntnisse darüber, wie gut sich Asthma medizinisch überhaupt überprüfen lässt?
Nee, kann ich hier im Detail nichts sagen, also ich glaube aus den Sachen, die ich aus der Vergangenheit von Radsportgeschichten weiß, dass das so ziemlich einfach durchgewunken wird. Also das ist sozusagen ein Art, da findet eigentlich jeder seinen Arzt, der dafür eine medizinische Ausnahmeregelung schreibt und die Reihenfolge ist vielleicht wichtig zu wissen, wie sowas funktioniert, also man kriegt, man muss einen Arzt finden, das ist ja dann meistens der persönliche Arzt bei so Individualsportarten oder der Mannschaftsarzt bei so Teamsportarten, der einem sozusagen das einmal genehmigt, einen dafür sozusagen sagt, du brauchst das auf ein Dokument und damit geht man dann zu dem Sportverband, der zuständig ist darüber zu entscheiden bei der Weltmeisterschaft die FIFA und die muss dann wiederum sagen, ja das passt dazu, das hat sich über die Jahre auch gewandelt, also mittlerweile werden da mehr die nationalen Antidopingbehörden mit reingezogen und die Weltantidopingagentur. Früher war das alles noch mehr in der Aufsicht der Sportverbände, aber sowas ist sozusagen die Reihenfolge, die ist glaube ich wichtig zu verstehen, weil wenn man dann Personen seines Vertrauens hat im medizinischen Bereich, ist das glaube ich nicht so ein Problem, das durchzubekommen. Was ich aber noch zum DFB sagen wollte, ich habe da jetzt selber meine Erfahrung gemacht, mir ging es, ich habe auch beim DFB Anfragen gestellt, genau zu dem Thema und dann auch noch wegen den anderen Themen, die geleakt wurden und das fand ich jetzt ein bisschen schwierig, die Kommunikation vom DFB, der sich dafür jetzt nicht so richtig scheinbar zuständig gefühlt hatte, auf Fragen direkt zu antworten, also sie könnten ja sehr schnell irgendwie klarstellen, was da jetzt genau der Grund war und der DFB hat einen interessanten Kommunikationsweg gewählt, in dem sie erst mir gegenüber jedenfalls gesagt haben, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei SRZ war, wir sind dafür nicht zuständig, das macht die NADA, die muss darüber entscheiden. Aus meiner Sicht falsch, das habe ich dem DFB auch geschrieben, weil sie am Ende immer darüber entscheiden, ob jemand gesperrt wird oder nicht, wenn ein positiver Test erfolgt. Darüber haben wir hier in der Vergangenheit ja auch schon gesprochen. Sie sind sozusagen für das Ergebnismanagement, so heißt dieser sperrige Begriff, zuständig. Und am Ende hat der DFB entschieden, na gut, dann schreiben wir jetzt nach dem Bericht, veröffentlicht wurden bei SRZ ja nochmal irgendwie so ein extra Artikel nur zu dem Thema Asthma-Sprays bei WM 2010, dann veröffentlicht man mal dazu eine Stellungnahme nachhinein. Das finde ich einen sehr schweren Kommunikationsweg, auch gerade wenn Journalisten versuchen, die Sache besser zu verstehen, dass man quasi nur als Reaktion dann nochmal dazu was veröffentlicht und nicht vorher versucht, mit den Journalisten ins Gespräch zu kommen und mit denen mal in Ruhe erklärt, was da eigentlich los war.
Und der DFB kennt dich und deine Recherche natürlich. Du betreibst unter anderem die Seite fußballdoping.de, bist schon seit Jahren tief im Thema. Das heißt, die hatten es da auch nicht mit einem Unbekannten zu tun. Nichtsdestotrotz muss man sagen, das hier ist alles vollkommen legal. Es ist nicht mal genau nachzuweisen, welchen wirklichen positiven Einfluss es gibt. Die Korrelation aus Sportlern, die angeben Asthma zu haben und Spitzensport, gerade aus anderen Sportarten, lädt zu einem gewissen Verdacht nahe, dass es einen Vorteil in sich birgt. Aber wir haben hier, wir wissen ja nicht mal, ob überhaupt zum Beispiel die deutschen Spieler jetzt während der WM 2010 diese Mittel genommen haben. Sie hatten nur das Recht, diese Mittel zu nehmen, wenn sie sie gebraucht hätten, aufgrund ihrer medizinischen Indikation.
Genau, und man kriegt auch für vier Jahre dann, wenn man, also damals war das so, dass man gleich für vier Jahre sich das genehmigen lassen kann. Also es kann auch sein, dass das vorher mal verwendet wurde. Das ist komplett richtig. Und was nochmal wichtig ist, mir hat eine Person aus der WADA, jemand, der ziemlich gut Bescheid weiß, auch noch ein bisschen, dem möchte ich mich auch darüber unterhalten, erzählt. Also wenn ich jetzt wirklich dopen würde, das Letzte, was ich machen würde, ist mir dafür eine mechanische Ausnahmenehmigung geben zu lassen. Also auch wenn ich die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß sehe, dass das irgendwie durchgeht, weil ab da wird es ja irgendwo protokolliert, was ich dann nehme. Das muss man auch mal im Hinterkopf haben, glaube ich, bei der Sache. Das sind Sachen, wo auch die Spieler irgendwie damit rechnen mussten, dass mehrere Menschen mitbekommen, was sie da nehmen. Auch wenn sie jetzt nicht damit gerechnet haben, dass es so mit deren Namen irgendwann mal veröffentlicht wird, viele Jahre später. Aber wer wirklich richtig dopen will, der macht das nicht über so einen offiziellen Weg.
Und trotzdem habe ich hier anmoderiert mit Doping im Fußball und so weiter. Und das, obwohl wir bei diesem einen Fall jetzt alle Einschränkungen machen müssen, die wir jetzt gerade gemacht haben. Das bezieht sich vor allem auf die weiteren Dokumente, die geleakt wurden. Kannst du uns dazu noch ein bisschen was sagen? Welche Erkenntnisse gibt es daraus?
Genau, ich mache jetzt erstmal die Kurzform. Also es gibt ein Dokument, wo das ist aus meiner Sicht das spannendste Dokument, wo interne Laborergebnisse veröffentlicht wurden, aus dem Jahr 2016 bis zum Februar 2017, wo ein Großteil der Proben, die in Laboren in aller Welt analysiert wurden, im Bereich Fußball aufgeführt sind. Also man muss sich so vorstellen, man hat eine Tabelle, eine Excel-Tabelle, ganz normal mit 5.000 bis 6.000 Zeilen. Und jede Zeile steht sozusagen für eine Lopingprobe.
Ganz normal, was sagst du für Excel-Tabellen?
Also schon eine gut gefüllte Excel-Tabelle, aber ich wollte das jetzt mal in Excel-Form erklären. Also man hat 5.000 bis 6.000 Zeilen und die erste Zeile ist, ich weiß nicht, ob die Zeilenreihenfolge jetzt richtig ist, aber auch egal. Also du hast eine Spalte, wo der Name von einem Labor drin steht, also was die Analyse durchgeführt hat. Man hat eine Spalte, wo ein Datum drin steht, wann wahrscheinlich die Analyse durchgeführt wurde. Man hat auch noch eine Spalte, wo drin steht, was war das Ergebnis von dem Test. Gab es eine auffällige Probe? Also da beginnt so zu einem Prozess, bis hin zu möglicherweise einem Dopingfall. Oder war das Ergebnis negativ und die konnten das quasi einfach zu nackten legen? Und in diesem Dokument von 2016 bis Anfang 2017 tauchen 200, jetzt muss ich sehr mal nachschauen, 229 positive Dopingproben im Fußball auf. Das ist erstmal insofern interessant, weil wir das bisher noch nicht wissen. Also klar, kriegen wir in Deutschland, können wir irgendwie mitkriegen, was gab es da für Dopingfälle und für auffällige Proben. Da kann man sich zum Beispiel einen Jahresbericht von der NADA anschauen, der schon veröffentlicht wurde. Aber wir haben das noch nicht weltweit oder europaweit erfasst. Das ist insofern schon mal neu und interessant. Beim Jahr zuvor gab es nur 160 positive Proben. Also wenn das so stimmt, das ist sozusagen das große Fragezeichen, da können wir gleich noch mal drüber reden, was wir noch ansetzen. Dann gab es einen deutlichen Anstieg von positiven Fällen in den Laboren. Das ist ein Dokument, jetzt springen wir noch kurz zum nächsten, kurz in Kurzform. Dann gab es ein Dokument, das sehr detailliert ist, zum Jahr 2015, wo auch genau diese Sachen drinstehen. Da kommt man genau auf 160 positive Dopingfälle. Und für dieses Jahr 2015 wurde auch schon in einem Bericht von der WADA mal veröffentlicht, wie viele Fälle es gab. Und da steht auch dran 160 Fälle, das spricht sozusagen ein wenig für die Glaubwürdigkeit des Dokuments. Was aber sehr spannend ist in dem Dokument, da kann man dann tatsächlich auch ein bisschen Zeit drin verbringen, ist, dass man genau sieht für jede Probe, was wurde denn jetzt im Labor genau analysiert. Also man kann richtig sehen, auf welche Substanzen wurde so eine Dopingprobe analysiert. Weil es ist nicht so, dass jede Probe, jede Urinprobe oder Blut, die zwei Möglichkeiten gibt es ja immer, auch wirklich auf alle Sachen getestet wird. Das ist viel zu teuer, das kann sich ein Labor nicht leisten. Und da könnte man jetzt etwas Zeit investieren und einfach mal auswerten, welche Substanzen werden überhaupt in der Regel getestet, welche oftmals nicht. Da wären ja auch interessante Ergebnisse, mit welchen Substanzen kommt man ganz gut durch, weil die vielleicht die Analyse zu teuer ist oder so was.
Ja, oder welche Dopinglabore haben vielleicht auch blinde Flecken. Da werden wir auch gleich noch kurz drüber sprechen müssen.
Ja und man sieht auch die zuständige Behörde, also wer wird nach dem Test informiert, an wen geht das. Das ist alles sehr schön detailliert aufgeführt. Hat mir auch viele neue Erkenntnisse gebracht, obwohl ich mich ja schon ein bisschen damit beschäftigt habe. Und dann gibt es noch mehrere Dokumente, über die ich irgendein englischsprachiges Medium habe ich darüber gelesen. Ich glaube, es war in der BBC, dass es noch interne E-Mails gibt, die mitgelegt wurden, die ich zugegebenermaßen am Anfang gar nicht entdeckt habe, weil sie einfach noch in einem anderen Link versteckt waren, wo man richtig Kommunikationsverkehre nachlesen kann, zwischen der FIFA, den einzelnen Ländern, wenn ein positiver Test passiert ist. Was kommt denn dann bei der FIFA an? Wie reagieren die darauf? Es gibt auch einen deutschen Fall, über den bisher nicht berichtet wurde, der da drin auftaucht, bei einem Spiel aus der vierten Liga. Und da kann man nochmal richtig, also ich glaube, es lohnt sich, dass da Journalisten noch mehr Zeit investieren, also auch gerne andere Leute, die sich dafür interessieren. Da könnten noch ein paar interessante Erkenntnisse zustande kommen.
Jetzt ist ja aber ein positiver Doping-Test nicht gleich auch ein Doping-Befund. Es gibt immer nochmal einen zweiten Test, eine A-Probe, eine B-Probe. Kann man denn sagen, wir sprechen ja jetzt hier über 229 positive Tests im Jahr 2016, das heißt fast an jedem Tag einer. Na ja gut, sehr weit abgerundet. Aber um das kurz zu verdeutlichen für die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen, die vielleicht auch immer noch sagen, auch nachdem sie vielleicht unser Tribünengespräch vielleicht noch nicht gehört haben, was soll denn Doping im Fußball überhaupt bringen? Hört euch das Tribünengespräch an, haben wir da sehr lange diskutiert. Weiß man denn, wie viele positive Dopingbefunde es auf Basis dieser positiven Tests im Nachhinein auch gab?
Nee, das ist tatsächlich schwierig jetzt auszuwerten. Man muss nur noch vorsichtig sein, genau die Gründe, die du genannt hast, ich ergänze mal vielleicht noch, also es gibt die positive A-Probe. Das ist der erste Schritt, das ist das, was wir in der Tabelle sehen. Dann kann sich der Athlet entscheiden, lässt er die B-Probe öffnen, die wurde damals einfach mit abgegeben, aber nicht sofort analysiert. Dann müsste man gucken, ob die auch positiv ist und dann geht es sozusagen los, dass man entscheidet, was passiert. Es kann nur auch sein, dass der Athlet sagt, hier ich hatte doch eine medizinische Ausnahmegenehmigung, die habt ihr bei euch im System gar nicht erfasst, hier reiche ich sie nochmal nach und schon wird daraus kein Dopingfall. Oder ich habe eine gute Begründung, warum das Ergebnis standgekommen ist. Es gab irgendwie eine Verschmutzung der Zahnpasta.
Das rassistische Rindfleisch.
Ja, also da kann man, ich warte immer noch auf den ersten Buzzfeed-Artikel mit den 100 sinnvollsten, sinnlosesten Ausreden nach positiven Doping-Tests.
Das wird der Daniel bestimmt bald nachreichen.
Falls er die Zeit investiert, sich das anzuwöhnen. Ja, ich hoffe es. Dann kann es noch andere Gründe geben. Aber wie du sagst, der Weg dahin ist noch lang. Wir können aber nicht sagen, das können wir nicht umrechnen. Es ist nicht möglich, wie viele Doping-Fälle daraus entstanden sind. Aber es ist schon interessant zu sehen, wie oft es positive Tests gibt. Und dann mal genauer sich anzuschauen mit den ganzen Dokumenten, die da mitgelegt wurden. Wie genau kommunizieren die denn jetzt? Also reicht es, wenn dann irgendein Mediziner, den niemand kennt, der beim FIFA-Büro kommt dann irgendwie eine Mehlreihe rein, von einem Mediziner aus Algerien zum Beispiel, hier auf Arabisch auch noch geschrieben, im besten Fall. Ich habe doch hier eine medizinische Ausnahmegebung. Und wie viel Zeit investiert dann die FIFA, um dem nochmal nachzugehen, ob das auch alles so stimmt? Und da fand ich jetzt so, auf den ersten Blick hat man gemerkt, wie viel die da zu tun haben. Da läuft auch alles über den einen Person. Weber heißt der Nachname von der FIFA, medizinischer Direktor, der dann sozusagen auch da überall einmal involviert werden muss bei jedem auffälligen Test. Und ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel Zeit er am Tag hat, um sich dann wirklich alles mit tiefen Recherchen, mit seinen Kollegen zusammen nochmal anzuschauen.
Und wenn alles über eine Person läuft, dann kann das auch so laufen wie im russischen Antidoping-Labor. Das sind ja noch jetzt keine neuen Erkenntnisse, die hier mit zusammenhängen, die aber wichtig sind, und die wir jetzt auch gleich mal über die Quelle dieser Daten sprechen. Es gibt den russischen Ex-Antidopingagenturchef Grigori Rogenko, der ist inzwischen geflüchtet aus Russland. Es gibt eine sehr gute Netflix-Dokumentation über ihn. Und er ist der Whistleblower, der im Wesentlichen viele Dinge, die man vielleicht schon vermutet hat, aber in ihrer krassen Ausprägung dann vielleicht doch nicht zu glauben wagte, jetzt veröffentlicht hat. Unter anderem hat er auch fast in so einem Nebensatz erwähnt, ja er hat auch schon am Doping-Programm für die Fußball-WM 2018 für die russischen Sportler gearbeitet, wie man da verschleiern könnte, dass russische Fußballer dopen. Er musste nur vorher das Land verlassen, aus Angst vor der eigenen Regierung. Was kannst du denn über ihn sagen?
Genau, also Werbung für die Doku hast du schon gemacht. Also es lohnt sich wirklich, das nochmal anzuschauen, auch wenn man es die letzten zwei, drei Jahre verfolgt hat, was alles aufgeklärt wurde, rund um ihn, was im Bericht aufgetaucht ist. Man kriegt nochmal einen ganz anderen Einblick in den Kulissen, was das für ein Typ ist, ein ziemlich verrückter. Und wie sehr auch der Russische Staat involviert gewesen ist, was ja sozusagen der Russische Staat bisher geleugnet hat bei den ganzen Dopingmanipulationen. Zu dem Thema gibt es heute im Spiegel einen Text, den ich noch nicht lesen konnte, aber ich habe nur die Vorabmeldung gelesen, obwohl sie tatsächlich das Thema nochmal aufgreifen, dass er zugegeben hat, dass er für die WM 2018 auch so ein staatlich organisiertes Doping-Manipulationsprogramm entwerfen sollte. Und da stehen, glaube ich, nochmal ein paar neue Details, über die wir jetzt leider gar nicht so aktuell sprechen können. Also kauft euch doch einfach mal ein Spiegel und lest es nach.
Also ich habe ihn auch schon gelesen. Ist sehr empfehlenswert. Wenn man die, na natürlich Jonathan, bitte. Wenn man die Doku auf Netflix gesehen hat, dann erfährt man da nochmal so ein bisschen best of. Und ansonsten sind es vor allem die kleinen Details, die einen wirklich sprachlos machen. Also nochmal das berühmte Loch in der Wand des eigens für die Olympischen Winterspiele in Sochi entworfenen Doping-Labors. Durch das dann die russischen Proben gereicht wurden und die dann diese Grigori Rodchenko höchst selbst zauber gemacht hat, indem er den enthaltenen Urin weggeschmissen hat, neuen Urin rein und den dann entsprechend eingefarbt hat, damit auch alles mit Gewicht und Farbung des Urins usw. übereinstimmt.
Ja und auch dazu, ich finde es auch so abgefahren, dass das wirklich so abläuft, wie man sich das immer so ein bisschen aus Filmen dann noch vorgestellt hat. Also ich dachte, das war doch früher so, ist das jetzt wirklich noch so? Also auf der anderen Seite des Lochs, wo es durchgereicht wurde, steht dann auch wirklich der russische Geheimdienst, die nebenan sich noch ein Gebäude gemietet haben, heimlich. Und dort wird das ganze Ding dann halt ausgetauscht, bevor er da weiter manipuliert. Also ist es wirklich so einfach, habe ich mir die ganze Zeit gedacht, beim Dokuschauen. Aber es scheint, ja also Filme scheinen dann doch irgendwie die Realität öfters mal abzuspiegeln. Ja, dann weißt du ja mehr als ich jetzt zur WM 2018, wenn du einen Spiegeltext gelesen hast.
Also erstmal glaube ich nicht, dass ich in diesem Bereich mehr wissen kann als du. Nein, es wurde eben leider nur in einem Nebensatz abgehandelt, auch in der Hauptgeschichte, was mich insofern etwas enttäuscht hat, weil der Teaser ja unter anderem sich vor allem darum drehte. Man kann davon ausgehen, wenn man zumindest diese Spiegelgeschichte, diesen Artikel liest, dass etwas ähnliches wie es in Sochi durchgezogen wurde, nämlich mit einem systematischen Doping der russischen Athleten, das dadurch verschleiert wurde, dass einfach die Proben ausgetauscht wurden. Also sprich, man musste sich gar keine Sorgen mehr darum machen, wie machen wir das jetzt rund um den Wettkampf, fahren wir da unser Doping zurück, wie lange ist das nachweisbar? Diese Fragen hat man sich nicht gestellt. Man ist quasi den kurzen Weg gegangen und hat einfach die Proben gefälscht. Es ist zu vermuten, dass etwas ähnliches für die russische Mannschaft, für die WM 2018 auch aufgebaut werden sollte, durch Rodchenko laut dessen eigener Aussage.
Vielleicht kommen wir an der Stelle mal zu den Interessen des Leak-Gebers, also der Gruppe Fancy Bear, bevor wir das jetzt vergessen. Das muss man so zu einem Hinterkopf behalten, meine ganzen Geschichten. Das ist ja eine russische Hackergruppe, so weit kann man es, denke ich, sagen, wo es viele Indizien gibt, dass sie auch mit dem russischen Staat sehr eng verküpft sind. Also es gab mal von der Initiative Wirtschaftsschutz, die auch dem Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz angehört, sozusagen die mal so eine Meldung verschickt. Ende August war das, wo drin bestehende Indizien, das sind für eine Steuerung durch staatliche Stellen in Russland zu dieser Hackergruppe. Und es passt auch zu den Leaks, die sie bisher veröffentlicht haben, wo es nicht um russische Athleten ging. Also sie haben ja schon mehrere Leaks im Sport. In den letzten Jahren, kann man sagen, veröffentlicht, wo auch wirklich große Namen aufgetaucht sind. Sie haben aber auch viel durch die Art, wie sie diese Leaks kommuniziert haben, missführende Äußerungen damit veröffentlicht. Auch diesmal stand ja sowas drin wie alles noch unveröffentlichte Doping-Fälle. Zum Beispiel haben wir gerade darüber geredet, man kann nicht von Doping-Fällen sprechen. Es stimmt auch nicht, dass sie alle unveröffentlicht sind, denn im VADA-Jahresbericht tauchte für 2015 schon viel auf. Da muss man sehr genau auf die Sprache achten. Was ich auch spannend finde, dass diese Gruppe ja auch die sein soll, die hinter dem Bundestag-Hack steckt. Wenn wir über Sport und Fußballdoping reden, wollen wir da so tief eintauchen. Aber das ist ja dieser Hack, wo über mehrere Tage Bundestagsabgeordnete getrackt wurden und Daten von den Rechnern gesaugt wurden. Wo vermutet wurde, dass in den nächsten Wochen vor der Wahl auch mal was veröffentlicht werden muss, um die Wahlstimmung noch ein bisschen mitzusteuern. Das muss man alles sehen. Und man muss auch sehen, was passiert ist im Sport mit den ganzen Sachen, über die wir jetzt schon gesprochen haben, die aufgedeckt wurden, den Wind, den unbischen Sommerspielen, wo die russischen Leichtathleten nicht mitfahren durften. Und diese große Diskussion, die immer noch im Gange ist, auch wenn sie nicht mehr so groß ist, ist es richtig, dass 2018 die Weltmeisterschaft in Russland ausgetragen werden sollte. Und das sind, glaube ich, alles eine Art Propagandamittel, um die Diskussionen mal ein bisschen Richtung Westen zu steuern. Was ich jetzt aber journalistisch wichtig finde, ist, man muss sich ja dann die Frage stellen, darf ich damit überhaupt was machen, wenn es solche Interessensgesteuerten Leaks gibt. Ich finde, ja, man muss halt sehr genau schauen, was verifiziert werden kann. Und dann kann man das auch journalistisch auswerten. Es gibt eigentlich jeden Leak, den man bekommt, ist ja irgendwie Interessensgesteuert. Das muss man sozusagen einmal verstehen. Und wenn man über die Sachen verifizieren kann, kann man ja trotzdem dadurch eine Einordnung betreiben.
Ja, wobei die Verifikation natürlich schwierig ist. Die Hacker selbst sagen, alle Daten entstammen den Systemen der Weltantidopingagentur WADA, die selbst sagt, nein, unsere Systeme sind sicher, das heißt schon, der Ursprung der Leaks der Daten, die dahinterstehen, ist unklar. Und dann stelle ich mir die Frage, wie genau kann man das wirklich überprüfen? Auf der einen Seite ist natürlich gerade der Detailreichtum ein Argument dafür, für die Echtheit der Daten, denn wer kann das so detailliert alles fälschen? Ihr sprecht auch selbst in eurem Artikel auf CORRECTIV, den ich natürlich auch verlinken werde, davon, dass unter anderem Anmerkungen der einzelnen Dopinglabors in der jeweiligen Landessprache gemacht wurden. Andererseits, wenn wir es hier mit staatlich geduldeten oder vielleicht sogar geförderten Hackern zu tun haben, das ist ja auch alles immer noch mit einem kleinen Fragezeichen, zumindest vielleicht sogar mit einem großen Fragezeichen, dann hätten die natürlich auch die Ressourcen sehr, sehr aufwendig, Dinge zu faken.
Absolut. Also ich glaube, man muss über jeden Punkt, über den man jetzt sagen wir mal detailliert berichten will, außer im Konjunktiv zu schreiben, mutmaßlich gab es so und so viel Dopingfälle in dem Jahr oder positive Proben. Wenn man ins Teil geht, dann muss man mindestens genug Zeit lassen, die Leute zu konfrontieren und dadurch auch zu verifizieren, die sozusagen damit was zu tun hatten. Also was ich zum Beispiel gemacht habe am Anfang auch, um so ein paar Echtheitschecks zu machen, ich habe die alle Dopingproben, die positiv waren, mal rausgesucht, die so große Organisationen betreffen. Also zum Beispiel gab es sechs Proben, die unter die Zuständigkeit der UEFA gefallen sind und habe diese rausgesucht, detailliert aufgeschrieben und die UEFA damit konfrontiert. Stimmt das? Und bei Twitter haben wir das jetzt öffentlich bei Fußballdoping. Dort wurde uns zum Beispiel bestätigt, diese sechs Fälle, das ist richtig, die gab es und die UEFA hat uns auch sehr detailliert, vielleicht waren es auch fünf, aber zu jedem Fall geantwortet, was da genau passiert ist, warum manche Fälle zum Doping-Fall wurden, manche aber auch nur positive Proben geblieben sind und dann eingestellt wurden. Und dadurch kann man ja sozusagen jetzt so einen Verifizierungscheck zumindestens für einzelne Elemente, Informationen nehmen, über die man dann auch berichten kann. Ich würde jetzt niemand anfangen, da kann ich keine Ahnung, es gibt einen total spannenden Kommentar von irgendeinem Labor, wo drin steht, wir haben eine Anweisung bekommen von den Deutschen, wir sollen ja unsere Probe manipulieren. Das würde ich nicht als Wahr erstmal nehmen, sondern da muss man dann schon mit Instruktion sprechen. Und was ich bei der Wahrheit ein bisschen schwierig finde, ist, dass sie nicht eindeutig sagen, was ist denn da jetzt manipuliert. Also es würde, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen helfen. Es gab schon vor ein paar Monaten, vielleicht auch schon ein Jahr her, als schon mal so ein großer Leak rauskam, hat die Wahrheit auch mal gesagt, das wurde manipuliert, hat aber nie in irgendeinem Fall ein Beispiel genannt, was jetzt konkret falsch ist in den Daten. Das ist jetzt, glaube ich, mehr so die Strategie, wir wollen uns damit jetzt nicht zu viel Aufmerksamkeit geben, wir halten uns zurück, Minimalkommunikation. Aber ich glaube, um sozusagen journalistisches Aufzufangen und einfach für Glaubwürdigkeit zu sorgen, muss man dann auch sehr konkret werden, was jetzt gefälscht ist.
Ja, jetzt haben wir viel mit der Lupe auf ein neues Puzzlestück rund um Doping-Tests im Fußball gesehen. Lass uns noch mal am Schluss die Linse aufziehen und das große Bild vervollständigen. Wir müssen jetzt nicht unser Tribüngespräch wiederholen und über den Sinn oder Unsinn von Doping beim Fußball und über die Kontrollen und wie das alles läuft. Das ist ja auch noch ein ganz eigener Aspekt, dass auch ganz viele Kontrollen einfach auch gar nicht stattfinden. Aber wie bringt uns jetzt dieser Leak voran? In welche Richtung schiebt er die Diskussion deiner Meinung nach?
Erstmal finde ich es gut, dass wieder einmal breiter über Doping im Fußball gesprochen wird, dass es weiter ein Thema bleibt. Das finde ich, glaube ich, wichtig, damit sich Sachen auch verändern können, dass Leute auch, dass das mehr sozusagen in der Öffentlichkeit auch immer klarer wird, dass es auch ein Sport, der manipuliert wird. Das bringt erst mal was, so und jetzt der konkrete Leak. Ich glaube, da muss man jetzt ein bisschen abwarten, was passiert und wie viel Zeit Leute da jetzt investieren, um noch Sachen auszuwerten. Er bringt jetzt erstmal, ich glaube, man muss jetzt einfach journalistisch kritisch da weiter dran bleiben, jetzt ganz normal bei der Saison, die jetzt beginnt und vielleicht kann man daraus auch einzelne Erkenntnisse zählen, wo dann zwischendurch man den Abläufe auch besser versteht. Das bringt mir zum Beispiel konkret gerade sehr gut was, dass ich sehe, okay, es gibt einen positiven Test in Deutschland, habe ich noch gar nicht darüber nachgedacht, in der vierten Liga. Und die FIFA muss darüber informiert werden, scheinbar. Das kommt ganz oben bei der FIFA auch einmal an. Und die geben dann auch nochmal das Go an den DFB. Ja, ist okay, wie das jetzt so gelaufen ist. Das war mir noch gar nicht klar, dass die FIFA da überhaupt eine Rolle spielt. Und so kann ich sozusagen journalistisch auch weiter ansetzen bei Recherchen. Das bringt, hat allein schon was gebracht. Und ich glaube, dann dürfen wir aber genauso gut nicht vergessen, dass jetzt so langsam rollen wir auf die WM 2018. Und vorher gibt es ja vermutlich gibt es noch Konfett-Cups.
Nein, der ist jetzt durch, der ist durch. Bist ein bisschen raus aus dem Fußball, was?
Oh man, ja doch, ich habe sogar Spiele gesehen. Sorry, ich, Sommerferien.
Ja, ja und Kindsholz, ich kenne das ja.
Okay, ja stimmt, wir hatten ja so viele neue deutsche Nationalspiele. Ups, genau, also jetzt ist glaube ich auch ein guter Zeitpunkt, um sich selber auch mal darauf vorzubereiten, was uns in Russland da erwartet und man hat ja echt viel gelernt, wie in Russland solche Manipulationen funktioniert. Vielleicht fallen da ja auch ein paar journalistische Ideen ein, wie man das ganze Thema dann abdecken kann.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite muss ich auch sagen, die Kurzpässe, die ich bisher mit dir zu dem Thema aufgenommen habe, die markieren dann immer schon fast das Ende der journalistischen Auseinandersetzung mit den Themen, denn ich reagiere damit auf aktuelle Berichterstattung, warte immer noch meistens so ein, zwei Tage, ob noch was nachkommt, und dann spreche ich mit einem Experten wie dir über das Thema. Und danach kann man ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr so viel über Doping im Fußball sprechen, außer man mit scholl tut uns den Gefallen und weigert sich öffentlichkeitswirksam, sich mit diesem Thema zu befassen. Naja, hast du recht.
In dem Fall muss man sagen, kann man jetzt auch bei dem Fall fast schon wieder sehen, dass jetzt hauptsächlich die Berichterstattung rund um die WM 2010, um diese Ausnahmengenommnung, dass die sich hauptsächlich darauf konzentriert hat.
Das ist ja eigentlich das schwächste Dokument.
Ja, aus meiner Sicht. Also das ist das deutlichste Dokument, ja, so vielleicht.
Stehen da Namen drin.
Alles genau. Man weiß, es kann relativ schnell auseinanderklamü sein, worum es da im Detail geht. Und die komplizierten Dokumente, wo es dann wirklich in die Tiefe geht, auch die schwierigsten, am leicht manipulierbarsten Dokumente, da geht es jetzt noch nicht so drum. Meine Hoffnung ist trotzdem, dass Leute da jetzt einfach gerade ein bisschen Zeit investieren und nicht sofort sich trauen, darüber zu berichten. Aber ich gebe dir recht, vielleicht bin ich da jetzt auch sehr optimistisch.
Es ist ein kompliziertes Thema und auch deshalb muss ich dir ganz ehrlich sagen, weil man auch nicht immer gleich die Dopingkeule schwingen soll, nur wenn man einen positiven Test gesehen hat. Also natürlich gehen da schon mal so kleinere Alarmlampen an, aber es kann halt ganz, ganz viele Gründe geben für positive Befunde, die nicht unbedingt bestätigt werden müssen. Und dann, ab diesem Punkt wird es halt schon so wahnsinnig kompliziert.
Ja, bin ich beide. Deswegen muss man auch aufpassen, dass man nicht mit Namen einfach anfängt, ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Also das ist ja das Problematische. Man darf nie den Namen von Sportlern nennen, wo am Ende sich dann herausstellt, das war doch ganz anders. Aber es gab Begründungen dafür. Für mich finde ich auch viel spannender, das Systematische dahinter zu entdecken, um die Strukturen sich anzuschauen. Aber man muss auch sagen, das zeigt jetzt auch wieder, die WM 2010 und das Beispiel Berichterstattung, die Leute und die Medien, und dann aber auch die Leute interessiert, halt hauptsächlich das Name-Dropping am Ende. Ich muss dann schon lesen, wer sind jetzt genau diese vier Nationalspieler? Auch wenn ich vielleicht den ganzen Zeitmarkt noch nicht sofort verstanden habe oder gar keine Zeit hatte, jetzt den ganzen Text dazu zu lesen.
Klar, also ich kann dir ja schon sagen, welcher Artikel mehr geklickt wurde, der von CORRECTIV auf correctiv.org oder der auf sz.de in dem einen standen Namen der deutschen Nationalspiele, in den anderen wurden sie nicht namentlich erwähnt. Ja gut, ich habe von Journalismus gesprochen, Entschuldigung. Was können denn Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen tun, wenn sie sich für dieses Thema interessieren in all seiner Komplexität und da trotz aller wenig öffentlichen Berichterstattung in den großen Medien dranbleiben wollen?
Also was ich gerade spannend fand, vielleicht eine konkrete Sache ist, die Süddeutsche Zeitung hat vor zur Saisonbegehung so eine Verletzungsauswertung gemacht und dort auch mit einem Blog zusammengearbeitet. Ich glaube, er heißt Fußball, weißt du, es ist besserfußballvernetzung.net, das war irgendwie eine bisschen komische URL.
Fußballverletzung, genau, ja.
Ja, oder de. Also findet man, wirst du ja wahrscheinlich verlinken. Und das ist zum Beispiel eine Sache, die finde ich eigentlich, da kann man auch bei seinem Club, der einem am meisten interessiert, immer so ein bisschen dranbleiben, einfach schauen, was für Verletzungen werden dort immer passieren in einem eigenen Verein, wie lange sind die Spieler dann verletzt, wie lange müssen sie eigentlich verletzt sein, wenn man sich so ein bisschen mal beschäftigt, was so ein typischer Verlauf für die Verletzungen ist, wie schnell stehen sie wieder auf dem Platz, wird dann eigentlich bis zum Tag vorher oder bis zum Anfang gesagt, wir können uns nicht sagen, ob er spielen kann, was ein Zeichen dafür ist, dass er dann schon ziemlich unter Schmerzmitteln erst auf dem Platz steht, wenn er dann doch irgendwie in der Startelfe ist und so. Das finde ich schon mal, das kann man kritisch in seinem eigenen Club begleiten. Da gibt es eine tolle Auswertung, wie gesagt, mit der Süddeutschen zusammen, wo sie genau das sagen, es gibt immer mehr Verletzungen, aber die Spieler stehen auch immer früher auf dem Platz und das hat sozusagen Folgensperre. Das ist Folgensperr, weil die Leute dadurch auch eher zum Sportinvaliden werden können. Okay, dann leider nicht getroffen, weil es sind zwei Versuchen. Genau, okay. Und sonst folgt uns doch gerne auf Fußballdoping, auf Twitter und Co. Wir versuchen das immer sehr aktuell dran zu bleiben. Wir sind auch nicht die, die jede Woche eigene Recherchen nachlegen, aber wir informieren zumindest über die Sachen, die weltweit passieren und wo andere drüber berichten.
Genau, ihr habt auch ein Newsletter. Du bist zu finden als atjsachse bei Twitter. Jonathan, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass du mal wieder dir Zeit genommen hast für dieses Thema im Rasenfunk.
Danke für die Einladung.
Und euch lieben Hörern und Hörern, danke fürs Zuhören. Nehmt euch das Tribünengespräch zu Doping im Fußball vor, wenn euch der Themenkomplex etwas ausführlicher interessiert und ansonsten schauen wir doch einfach, was noch so auf uns zurollt. Es wird ja noch ganz viele Themen dazu geben. Bis dahin, bis zum nächsten Kurzpass. Macht's gut.